how important is your online footprint
if you will to your acting career like
you're acting website your social media
how important is all about yeah it's uh
it's pretty important especially coming
from the comedy world because if you're
not trying to make a joke on Twitter
someone else from you know Cincinnati
Ohio already is or someone can be e to
the punch so you're that like pawns
great good it's good but it is there's
you know there's different ways it's
kind of a crazy changing landscape but
there's different ways go about twitter
and instagram facebook and then your own
personal website as well but if someone
wants to cash in something and there's a
guy let's say his name's Chad because
that's what we're going with today looks
just like me and he has a real up and I
don't at least they have something to go
off of already before he even gets in
the room and it gives them a leg up and
the competition per se but it is you
just have to it's it's weird to say I
guess in a way but if you were to Google
somebody and up-and-coming actor writer
producer whatever and they you know
server can't be reached or Nothing guys
up for air you're gonna have that kind
of like Boldin what do you do it are you
really actually working or you lie in it
it is it's beneficial in all ways I mean
people that's how I mean look at YouTube
celebrities and YouTube stars people are
making their own living just kind of off
their own personality and using social
media as a platform to gain fans to gain
likes to gain shares and then comes the
branding and then comes the
advertisements and ability to make money
based off of your own personality which
at the end of the day Facebook Twitter
Instagram that's all you wrapped into
kind of one in a way a way for people
that don't know you personally to think
they know you personally right and then
your own website your professional
website however you want to approach it
as a actor model writer your portfolio
links i mean everyone out here from a
you know a cinematographer to an editor
they all have their own wheels up and
you need that to prove your work you
know i mean if you make a sports
reference you'd rather want you you put
together a highlight tape too
yourself may be noticed by a college
recruit or whatever sport you're playing
it's the same thing here when it comes
to acting you got to put together your
highlight tape so the coach or the
casting director the producer can call
you up and put you in something well I
noticed with your site and it's anthony
hyphen finale not underscore hyphen yeah
you believe that I think some 14 year
old dirt bike rider bought the domain to
Anthony finale so if you're out there
you may not be 14 anymore but work well
you can check and see if it's expired
exactly but but so your site is
incredibly organized I have to say so oh
thank you amazing you have like is it
six different reals yeah there's a
couple different ones um there's the
master real which has everything from TV
film commercial there's a comedic real
there's a live comedy real commercial
real a hosting and spokesman real which
you know to people outside the industry
they're gonna all look the same but
within this you know entertainment
bubble that we work and live in out here
they're all very different and very
distinct and show your skills in a
different way when did you launch that
website I think I built it about a year
ago yeah and the reels I try to because
there's always new stuff coming out and
as an actor it's not the easiest thing
to do to get your footage so you have to
go around certain ways in order to find
it so you know if you film something
last week it may not even come out for
like seven months and it's on your
resume and but no one can you know
visually see it or hear it until it
actually comes out so you have to keep
building your your real up as much as
possible yeah so 2012 is when you were
here at late-september ish but then it
took you a few years to actually get all
that material yeah I had a I had a
decent amount of footage from when I
lived in Chicago from working on some
commercials there which was good so at
least got my foot in the door with some
agencies and managers that were like
okay he's not didn't just wake up one
day and be like I'm gonna go act for a
living that was my impersonation I'm
greater than person ations as you can
tell but I wasn't that person you know I
had a little bit like you said I
prepared as much as possible so before I
moved out here I actually sent out
headshots and reels to about four
agencies and i just googled la agencies
so that had your biggest ones all the
way to you know some guy that's faking
it living in his mom's basement that
says he's an agency i said him
everywhere so actually the day i got out
here i had two meetings set up which
were which was very nice but you know i
sent it out to so many those two got
back to me it was just the numbers game
at that point it's like cold Colin
really was and spending the money and
taking the time to physically I mean
2012 not too long ago it was right in
that transition of everyone going are we
just doing digital or do we want the
hard copies it still to this day it's a
toss up some people want them some
people don't but yeah it that's how I
got it and was having a little bit of a
real and saying I'm coming here from
Chicago here's what I've done there
here's what I can hopefully do out here
how often do you maintain your website
in terms of updating it with new stuff
because you seem very busy and I know
we've talked previously yeah today that
you have many things going on so how
often are you updating stuff anytime I
film something or write or produce
something that's actually been produced
I put I update my resume and then
anytime I've it's actually already
happened because there's a lot of you
know smoke and mirrors out here and a
lot of broken promises that do happen
unfortunately nature the business and so
I anytime actually something does come
to fruition I'll put it up there you
know recent news film this this got
picked up writing he grew four inches
overnight and now we can dunk a
basketball that's a joke stuff like that
I'll I'll throw it in there as soon as
it happens because people got if people
are looking they obviously wanna know
what's the most recent but you don't go
to someone's site and it's a you're not
gonna click on an actual site that has
and says like the newest posters in 2009
and it's not going to be relevant it's
just not right and like I said it's the
same thing with the jokes on Twitter
someone else is updating their thing or
someone else just shot something as well
it's a competitive there's a Chad and
Tyler out there looking just like me
ready to take it out from under me
you